con resultados electorales casi
idénticos a los del 2019 cuando el
presidente uruguayo luis lacalle pou
fuera elegido el domingo obtuvo una
ajustada victoria tras el referéndum de
la ley de urgente consideración que le
permitirá mantener sus políticas de
gobierno los uruguayos votaron sobre 135
artículos que se referían a seguridad
pública educación política fiscal
política de derechos laborales y ajuste
de precios entre otros temas el
49.9 por ciento votó por mantener estos
artículos mientras que el
48.8 votó por derogar los aunque ninguna
de las dos fuerzas obtuvo la mayoría a
los votos por mantener estos artículos
se sumaban los votos en blanco y es así
que se llegó a más de la mitad de los
votos lacalle pou festejo de forma
mesurada dijo que el referéndum era una
etapa superada
y que ahora se va a dedicar a nuevas
medidas como son las políticas de
vivienda y de seguridad social
entretanto la oposición dijo que el
presidente debería tomar nota de que el
50% de la población consideró que esos
artículos
violentaban sus derechos